hey James Corden why you want to yell
why did you just tweet as James him and
his wife go out for brunch James Corden
wife ordered an egg yolk omelet a few
minutes later they received the food
James called the server MK and told her
there was a little bit of egg white
mixed with the egg yolk the kitchen
remade the dish but unfortunately sent
it with home fries instead of salad
that's when James Corden began yelling
like crazy the server you can't do your
job maybe I should go to the kitchen and
cook The Omelette myself because it's
frustrating to get it wrong but they get
it wrong yeah I'm gonna go to the
kitchen do it just no you not you have a
kitchen dummy anyway yeah that's great
you can't speak to a waiter like that
and his whole personality is built on
being what a sweet guy is also you would
guess immigrant
treat Balthazar with respect that's an
American New York institution let's go
right now I'm going about this all right
now how much are we going to tip not
only am I gonna tip extra extra for him
is 20 yeah what's funny is that I'd want
to hurt you but no I think James cord is
wrong I tip more than all of you and
suck dick